by the way if anyone here is in
advertising or marketing kill yourself
advertising has made a very bad name for
itself we don't trust it or want much of
it around so it's resorted to springing
up on us in unexpected places by the
side of the road at a football match at
the airport jetway the relationship
between consumer and advertiser has
become like a constant game of nagging
and pestering the advertiser feels the
consumer doesn't really want what's on
offer but assumes that if it just keeps
popping up all the time and perhaps
cracks a joke or gets half-undressed
eventually the consumer will give up and
buy the damn toothbrush chocolate bar or
insurance policy badgering people can
feel like a natural strategy for
advertisers to fall back on when they're
striving to gain our attention after all
this is what we all did when we were
young and had no other options a 6 year
old has no capacity to rationally
persuade her parents to buy her a
goldfish but she will instinctively
assume that asking a million times might
just work occasionally it does when
we're under pressure at work and
stressed to keep our jobs in the agency
we return easily to such early badgering
instincts the lamentable thing is that a
badgering approach is however
unnecessary because it isn't as if
people don't want to buy things and have
no material needs we're constantly
needing and wanting to shop the act of
buying isn't something voice turd upon
us by an evil advertising industry as
people in advertising seemed somehow to
believe in their hearts it's something
we naturally and spontaneously feel
however could present
there's simply no incentive for us to
tell advertisers about what we might
need because we don't trust them not to
keep bugging us if ever we were to
reveal more about ourselves
they've annoyed us far too much already
for us to let on about our interests we
don't want to tell them that we're
potentially in the market for a new car
and wouldn't mind being shown some
options for a nice woolen jacket we'd
never share such private information
because we suspect how it might then all
go
we'd be bothered at nauseam possibly for
decades we wouldn't be presented with a
real range of options and our details
would be passed on to other firms
selling utterly offbeat things like
inflatable dinghies and lunchboxes so
instead we just lie low and remain
deeply guarded about sharing anything
about our lives which is what in turn
leads advertisers to bully us and spy on
us to track our online moves and when
they're really fed up and desperate to
bung up our computers with pop-ups the
relationship between customer and
advertisers has ended up marked by a
total lack of trust on both sides
customers don't trust that advertisers
will look after their real needs and
advertisers don't trust that customers
will listen to an honest pitch
however sad this does hint at the shape
of an eventual answer if advertisers
became more responsible and could be
trusted not to foist random things on
people then we would tell them about
ourselves in our needs the more we
thought well of them the more details
we'd reveal as we might to a friend but
we only become friends with people we
can trust and that to date can't
encompass the advertising industry if
these people want to earn our time and
sincere attention then they need to stop
tracking us with cookies and try to show
up with hardly any clothes on in weird
places advertisers need to learn not to
see themselves as fundamentally a
nuisance and behave with a sort of
dignity and self-respect of people who
know they could properly improve the
lives of others once they got to know
them well then we might start to listen
willingly
you
if you like our films take a look at our
shop the School of Life comm forward
slash shop you'll find lots of
thoughtful books games stationery and
more